jennifer machado used to run a soup
kitchen from her home to feed hungry
children in her neighborhood but not
anymore
when she refused to display a
pro-government poster in her house after
government losses in september's primary
elections her food supplies dried up
local media reports of her defiance had
apparently reached the highest levels
just weeks before sunday's far more
important legislative elections
they brought us these posters for us to
receive food and give it to the people
some people had no problem in taking
pictures with these posters but others
did not want to and we couldn't force
them everything they gave us we had to
take pictures now they took all the help
away from us and never brought food
again and now we're closed
jennifer lives in general rodriguez a
poor neighborhood about 40 minutes away
from the capital she has four children
the government launched a series of
measures to revert the setbacks it
suffered during the primary elections
last september those results show that
the government lost lots of support in
poor neighborhoods like this one and
that's why they started distributing
cash food among other things but polls
suggest it may not be working in their
favor
in addition to the poster jennifer says
she was also given a refrigerator three
days after the elections she says it was
an attempt to get her vote
in sunday's legislative elections people
will vote to renew half the chamber of
deputies and a third of the senate
at stake is president alberto fernandez
ability to govern effectively for the
remaining two years of his term marked
so far by economic hardship worsened by
the coveted 19 pandemic
the opposition says the government is
desperate to get votes
president alberto fernandez says his
priority is those in need
i've heard people tell me that inflation
worries them and i've also heard them
tell me their income is not enough and
so we listened and we changed and we
increased cash handouts so that those
with kids can improve their living and
have better conditions
argentina is currently negotiating an
almost 50 billion dollar loan with the
imf
inflation is close to 50 percent a year
and exchange rate controls make it
difficult for the economy to grow
divisions within the government on how
much money to spend on the streets have
heard the ruling coalition between
president alberto fernandez and his
powerful vice president christina
fernandez the kushner
but analysts say the biggest problem is
that argentina has no economic plan
the economy is disorganized investments
low so there's no drivers for the
economy they want to exacerbate
consumption but it means more inflation
or an impact on the exchange rate
difference that generates chaos the
government's adrift they change their
mind constantly one day they say they'll
negotiate with the imf then they won't
so who knows
argentina has been able to contain
social discontent using cash
distribution programs to assist those in
need but the elections show people want
much more they need jobs and prosperity
and the opportunity to change their
lives teresa al jazeera buenos aires